welcome back is the Ben Shapiro show
we're taking your phone calls at eight
five five to thirty six thirty to twenty
eight that's eight five five to thirty
six thirty to twenty eight Mario in
California you're on the bench pure
struggle for Mario hey how's it going
hey go for it sir so I have a few
questions I guess one is how has been
defined and I think it was Michael knows
moles who claims on your show ammonia
subbing in one day that homosexuality is
the deadliest of all sin so I was just
curious as to why homosexuality would be
propped up and labeled as the deadliest
thing as opposed to like murder so on a
fairly certain yeah so so I'm fairly
certain that that is not what he
actually said I think well I think well
I think what you're referring to is
Michael mole said that pride is the
deadliest sin right not gay pride just
pride generally and so you said that any
aspect in which you are sinning and then
you are prideful about your sin is the
deadliest sin so he wasn't saying that
like if you're prideful about being a
murderer presumably that would be
according to Knowles the deadly sin I I
really really do I mean I know my pretty
well I really don't think Michael thinks
that of all these sins that human beings
can commit homosexuality homosexual
activity is the deadliest sin by any
stretch by the way I think you're hard
pressed to find any religious figure who
actually believes that homosexual
activity is the deadliest of all sin I
mean even even the people who are super
anti-gay activity people who think that
it's a real sin I mean that the
perspective of religious people that
I've found is that I mean everybody sins
this is one sin among many sins that the
entire chapter in Leviticus that talks
about homosexual activity lists off 45
different types of sexual activity that
are banned right not 45 but it's a it's
more like at least a dozen maybe a
couple of dozen right you're not
supposed sleep with your aunt you're not
supposed to sleep with animals you're
not supposed to sleep with your father's
wife rightly there's like a bunch of
them and homosexual activity is just one
of many so they say that it's like
ranked higher on the scale of sin that I
don't think Michael has ever said in
order I think Michael maintains that
what he has said is that if you are
running around shouting about how you
are proud that you are committing what
is a biblical sin then that would be a
weird thing to do no matter what the
biblical scent is so I just want to be
fair to Michael who I mean let's be real
about this Michaels the worst but I
don't think that Michael actually said
that right Mario okay so is it because
of that pride that you think that there
is a particular resentment for
homosexuality and religious groups or
and what
people like me who like I'm a gay
conservative so like what can people
like me do who maybe don't prescribe to
a lot of the different things that come
along with you know the LGBT community
the hook-up culture the drugs and me
know first of all I'm not sure that
anybody should be particularly proud of
the sex that they are having okay so
it's it's oh it's it's one part of your
life right I mean it's it just as my
sexual relationship with my wife is one
part of my life
some people consider that sinful some
people consider that not sinful and
frankly you know I'm not sure why you
should care what what I have to say
about it right I mean like if I may not
like your perspective you may not like
mine as long as I'm not attempting to
cram down my perspective via the power
of government then I don't see why there
really should be a conflict on all of
this I mean when we're talking politics
specifically we are talking about the
role of the federal government or the
role of the state government in policing
particular activity I don't know a
single Republican in America really I
mean is it there they may exist I mean
I'm not saying they don't exist I'm sure
their son but I don't know any
Republicans right now who are calling
for the outlawing of gay sex for example
like that I think went by the wayside in
Lawrence vs Texas I mean in terms of
Supreme Court law which was 2003 so it's
been it's been quite a while here so as
far as sort of the generalized
perspective on why so many consumers are
upset about it I think conservatives are
upset about a couple of things when it
comes to when it comes to sort of the
gay pride movement one is the suggestion
that homosexual marriage and
heterosexual marriage are identical and
the same and work the same in terms of
moral value and that is a critique with
which I generally agree I think that
homosexual relationships are not built
around the bearing and rearing of
children whereas heterosexual
relationships ideally we're supposed to
be for that matter by the way not all
heterosexual relationships are created
equal
right this is why I am not in favor of
men and women living together in
so-called said right as a religious
person so so that I think people
disagree with I think the idea that we
that religious people are to be that
their children are to be forced by the
state to be taught this particular
version of sexual values namely that any
value that sexual consent is the only
value that's something the religious
people don't believe right religious
people believe that consent is a value
but it is not the only value meaning
there's lots of things people can sense
you
that on a religious level I object to
and think is a problem but when it comes
to government then we all agree then
then we generally agree that consensus
is the typical value that matters the
most Mario yeah okay so sorry to bog up
the line but outside of politics then
unlike the cultural level and in
personal relationships with what might
be the best way for me to I don't know
exactly what the question is yeah no I
mean I think that the if the question is
you know are religious people sitting in
judgment on you and judging you and
making fun of you behind your back or
something I don't think that's right I
really don't I mean and not if they're
good ready but let me put it that way I
think that well you know I'm not gonna
play the I'm not gonna play the I have
gay friends card cuz it's stupid but the
reality is that most but the reality is
the most religious people and most
conservative people know people who are
gay and they and even if they believe
that the homosexual activity itself is a
sin I know tons of people who are
sinners I'm a sinner we're all sinners
I've yet to meet a religious person who
doesn't believe that we all sin and then
the question is how you deal with that
sin and I don't actually have to you
know believe that what you're doing is
not a sin in order to say that you're
human being who's trying is best and and
a human being who's trying to do what
what you know they feel is right in life
and we can disagree on sin that's that's
okay and you don't you can't force me to
think that what you're doing is not
sinful and I can't force you to agree
that you ought to see some particular
activity via force of government yeah I
think it's difficult to feel like you're
fighting against resentment from certain
people but outside of that I'm not gonna
bog out the line anymore
yeah no I mean Mario I would say all I
would say is that I don't religious
people say this all the time and it is
actually true religious people resent
sin they do not resent the sinner and if
they resent the sinner and not the sin
then they're not being religious they're
actually violating the precepts of their
own religion and you can ask any pastor
a priest about this they would agree any
rabbi same thing okay really appreciate
it Mario thanks so much okay let's see
who else Matthew in Fredericksburg
you're on the bench pure struggle for
Matthew yes so I'm obviously living in
Virginia and we're going through our in
our government here all the gun laws
that are trying to pass gun control laws
and so forth I'm curious as if you know
how much after all this has said and
that the federal government could step
in and try to stop this infringement on
our Second Amendment so I think that it
is quite unlikely that the federal
government has the ability to step in
too much with regard to Virginia gun
laws it's up to the Supreme Court
unfortunately and theoretically you
could have the federal government pass
concealed carry reciprocity for example
and suggest that the privileges and
immunities Clause applies to gun
ownership that if you have a gun license
in one state you should be able to carry
that across state lines into another
state that could be done at the federal
level but I don't think that the federal
army is going to be sent in in order to
stop the stop the state of Virginia from
passing gun law I mean there's there's
effective gun law in California and New
York and Massachusetts all over the
country so unfortunately it's gonna have
to be fought out at the state level
Matthew which by the way is probably
where it should be fought out I mean
people tend to forget that the
Constitution of the United States
originally applied only the federal
government the Second Amendment there
may be a provision in the fet in the
Virginia State Constitution about gun
ownership I actually don't know the
Virginia Constitution all that well but
on the federal level the the the powers
that were prevented from government on
the federal level were prevented from
governments on the federal level that
didn't necessarily mean they were
prevented from government on the state
level right yeah and of course we don't
want to you know a government that just
comes in and they ever say every time
they don't like something and intervene
right we don't want that right exactly
maybe we have to opt for it we just have
to do harder work at the state level and
it seems like people in Virginia are
doing that by the way I think that the
the fight back against gun control in
Virginia will in the end be successful
there are too many gun owners and too
many people who leaving gun rights in
Virginia to for that to end any
differently Ian in Thousand Oaks
California on the bench of druglord Ian
fan of yours but I don't necessarily
agree with your stance on the Beatles
and I was wondering if you would be
willing to change your opinion on John
Lennon's song imagine no maybe I'd be
willing to hear I'd be willing to hear a
case but I cannot say I will find that
case convincing nor that I will take it
particularly seriously it's a horrible
horrible song it is a pretentious
ridiculous song it's suggestion that if
you imagine a world without borders
religion or heaven that this would
suddenly make things better that's just
the Soviet Union no borders no religion
no have
Brotherhood of man except for the
several tens of millions of people we're
going to have to murder in order to
effectuate that end it's a horrible song
it's just a horrible song in I
appreciate the call but I do appreciate
your optimism that you thought that I
would actually go for that already
coming up we're gonna bring you the
latest in the democratic 2020 race is
Michael Bloomberg the man with the
momentum this is the bench Bureau show